all right Betty Betty brick house right
yes that's the name you go by I it is
and uh tell me what you what do you call
what you do I am a fetish wrestler or
session wrestling uh I people pay me to
wrestle them for generally an hour or
two at a time um I also film uh
wrestling Customs uh which means like
men submit like a script I say men but
mostly men uh who they submit like a
script of things that they want to see
um and then I would basically act them
out um like a some type of wrestling
fantasy and this is a popular thing
among men it's it's definitely got a A
large group of people that enjoy it uh
there are there are clients all over the
country you're based where I'm in
Chicago you're in Chicago MH and I'm
sure you have clients there but you're
you're traveling around the country as
well uh yeah I have clients there I I
don't I did I've gone through uh years
of traveling quite a bit and then I've
gone through years where I haven't
traveled a lot I think you'll find most
session wrestlers or fetish wrestlers do
that um you kind of have like a year on
or a year off because you get really
tired traveling all the time I
understand that and this is a sexual
thing for these guys um sometimes but
not always I definitely have had a lot
of clients who they've told me that it
is genuinely just they've always always
wanted to be rough house with a woman um
they've rough housed with men growing up
and they always really enjoyed that and
because um it's more fun to have your
body up against someone that you're
interested in than um man if you're
straight then uh then wrestling really
is it for them but I've also met a lot
of them who wrestle men and women um
there's actually like male versus male
forums out there um where you can find
other men who will wrestle you don't
usually have to pay male wrestlers but
uh but they a lot of them will wrestle
people of multiple genders if they're
genuinely into wrestling then they do
that um if it's if it's more like a
fetish for them like if they're
interested in like a foot fetish session
uh it's like the same kind of thing as
wrestling it's the same like very
specific Kink that they have but for for
your clients who hire you they they're
clothed um most of the time yeah a lot
of times they'll wear boxers or swimming
trunks or something but yes and where do
where do you go to do this um I have a
studio in my basement I I have like 10
by 10 wrestling Mets uh as well as like
when I'm traveling what I typically do
is I get a suite and I drop the mattress
on the floor of the suite and then we'll
wrestle on there that works out that's
funny so the these guy these men
are former wrestlers or they just guys
that like to Rough House with women um
most of the time they're just guys that
like to Rough House with women I will
say that there's a good I definitely
have a handful of clients that were
wrestlers in high school um and like I
guess wrestling a lot gave them this
fantasy of like losing to a woman uh I
i' would say a lot of my clients are
definitely into the losing aspect
there's very few clients that I run into
that like really truly want to win is is
this a little bit of a dominatrix
submissive um a little bit yeah uh I
would I would I don't know a lot of them
don't want the other aspect that comes
with domination like they don't they
don't really want to be spanked they
don't really want to have like a collar
put on them they just literally want to
be overpowered um they want to be penned
to the ground they want to um know that
the woman is stronger than and that
they're
weaker
interesting and this is
uh these guys are married or is this
something all over the map I've
definitely had married clients I would
say that I I've lately I've run into
less married clients than single guys uh
I'm not sure why that is I think maybe
because uh kink and and alternative
lifestyles are becoming more mainstream
so you don't have to hide it from your
partner the way that you did um I I
think I think for some of them they view
it like going to a strip club because
they're not actually engaging in
anything that's could be considered
cheating um but it's still like it's
still I'm sure the wife would consider
it you know like going to a strip club
or worse it's probably healthy that the
fetish Kink Community is is becoming a
little more mainstream definitely agreed
yeah um I'm I'm very happy to see that I
would much rather see i' would much
rather see even less clients but more
people having uh more people having uh
satisfied their Kinks out in the in the
world without you know needing to
basically hide what they're interested
in yeah there's so much shame that could
be connected with all these kind of
behaviors exactly and there's really no
need for it no is really stigmatized uh
definitely a thing in the Kink Community
is like your Kink is not my Kink uh it's
a thing that we say a lot um and I
definitely I've gotten a lot of very
strange requests over the years like I
even like wrote them all down and in a
Google doc uh one time just so that I
could reference them like when I'm you
30 years from now when I'm not doing
this anymore just because I they're some
of them are just very bizarre and
specific but I still don't actually
judge any of them for having them I just
think they're really funny uh because
they're so unusual I had a I interviewed
someone recently who is an adult baby
diaper lover yes which for a grown man
to come out and say that he likes to
wear diapers you would think that'd be a
humiliating thing but it was funny to
hear him speak about it just about like
he's talking about how he likes to wear
blue jeans yeah some of them feel that
way and it it it kind of took the the
shame out of the equation absolutely uh
I I liked him much more because he was
so open honest about it I understandable
yeah I don't personally I that's one of
those things that I definitely every
time it comes up I'm like it's your your
Kink is not my Kink because I've had
I've had requests for people to do like
they'll like to combine Kinks like uh
let's wrestle while in diapers uh or
let's wrestle it's not just that like
they'll be like let's wrestle with your
foot in my face like that's how I want
you to win or they just have very
specific interests um and a lot of times
they don't feel sham about sometimes
they feel intense shame but a lot of
times they're just like this is what I
like and I'm I'm here and I am paying
you to do this and we're going to have a
good time it's it's almost
like I don't know what the word is it's
almost like heartwarming to see somebody
who has gotten over their shame
absolutely and just kind of like this is
just what I'm into yes I'm I'm 100%
there um and I'm super non-judgmental
when I'm with people so I think that
they feel more comfortable getting over
their shame and I think once you've sort
of taken that first step it's easier to
feel that with people who might try to
shame you yeah no I interviewed someone
else recently who um a couple a couple
gentlemen actually who who like to
hire uh transgender prostitutes MH and
the way the way these guys spoke about
it was like it's like that's what I had
for lunch yesterday it was like no big
deal that's funny and it was funny like
by the end of the talk you realized he's
just talking about what he enjoys yep
and it wasn't like this thing that
normally we would be like what a creep
right not at all I mean I think as soon
as you start putting money into the
equation and you're and consent I feel
like creep should be taken out of the
the the language altogether like you are
obviously you were paying for a service
who cares what that service is and as
long as you've done everything that
you've discussed beforehand and it's all
consensual like there should be no there
should be no shame around it personally
not hurting anybody yeah exactly and
like both people are benefiting from it
in that situation you know like the
person who's being paid to do the
service is getting something out of it
and then and maybe it's even their Kink
but the person who and then that person
who's paying is getting their King
satisfied and both people are probably
wearing a smile for a few days
afterwards absolutely absolutely and
that's only a good thing yeah I
definitely get a lot of joy out of uh
giving people something that they've
really really wanted or have really
struggled to get and and I get a lot of
clients like that in particular
because um it's very rare to find a
woman that can genuinely overpower you
even though there are hundreds of
session wrestlers out there uh most of
them are not actually stronger than all
men um do some do some men like
these smaller women that will be easier
to wrestle but they just like wrestling
with them they love the idea of these
women being super strong uh like the a
lot of them will Target in particular
bodybuilders but they don't realize that
bodybuilders don't actually have a lot
of strength outside of the very specific
movements that they do um and so when
they wrestle me I can actually win
they're the only time I have lost
against men is if they have a 100 pounds
on me or more um I've always been strong
and I do a lot of sports like I play
Roller Derby and I do sword fighting I
do a lot of sports to keep that way um
and and I can you know literally pick
someone up and lift them over my head if
they're under a certain weight and uh
and so that's what that's what some of
these guys really have always truly
wanted is to like actually lose and like
fight back as hard as they can and then
still lose um and so uh I definitely
feel special when I'm able to do that um
because a lot of a lot of people can't
um and they and a lot of them are still
even weaker than bodybuilders or
powerlifters or anything else um they're
just like a lot of men just haven't done
anything to work out or build up their
strength but if they have done any kind
of sport then almost always their
strength overpowers women how did how
did you discover that this was a thing
you could do uh so when I was 19 I was a
broke college student uh and I
constantly scoured Craigslist for in the
gigs section I like picked up a lot of
doing like a lot of Photography stuff um
you know I worked a lot of events but
one of the ones that came up was if you
are strong woman um I will pay you $150
to wrestle me there's no sex will both
be fully clothed you can wear whatever
you want and I'll meet you in advance
and we can have coffee so that you know
that I'm not a creeper and I was like
Sal uh I knew I I knew I was strong I've
always known that and I was playing R
Derby at the time anyway uh and so I met
him for coffee I think twice because I
was nervous about it uh and he was just
a super sweet old trucker who was
honestly using his Social Security he
was like saving it up every paycheck so
that he could pay for a session and
after the first time we had a session he
uh was like oh my God you're so good at
this you need to get on session girls
and then there's another site at the
time called like
wb270 and I was like okay and I did um I
didn't get a lot of clients because I
lived in Louisville Kentucky at the time
which is not a huge Center for travel or
for um I guess there's just not a lot of
people that are interested in wrestling
down there I only got a couple of people
in the city but when I traveled I would
get lit up with people in interested in
wrestling me in all these different
cities bigger cities have more of it
usually uh usually I think that would be
the case with most of the yeah the
fetish King crowd it's so the problem
with bigger cities is like I go to New
York City or I go to LA or La is a bad
example but let's go with I go to New
York City um there are already like 15
session wrestlers in New York city so if
somebody is really interested in
wrestling they could have kind of an
ongoing relationship with this wrestler
and so I don't get a lot of work when I
go to New York City and I've talked to a
lot of other wrestlers and they feel the
same way really you want to go someplace
there's kind of like a sweet spot where
you want to go to some place where there
are people but not necessarily
competition or a lot of competition at
least and a lot of us do better in the
South where it's more conservative uh
and then or DC like almost all of us do
well in DC H interesting how different
regions have absolutely yeah like I've
come to LA probably a dozen times at
this point and I get shoots when I'm
here but I don't think I've ever gotten
a
session interesting yeah whereas like
when I have gone to like Kansas City
I'll have five in one day so it's really
it's really all over the map for me
what's the craziest uh interaction
you've had with with your clients uh the
weirdest request that I had and this did
not turn into a session but the weirdest
request that I had was is that he wanted
me he wanted to rent an Airbnb with a
giant swimming pool and he wanted me to
dress up like a bodyguard in
heels and he wanted uh he was supposed
to be like a burglar and I was supposed
to tackle him into the water and uh hold
him under the water and let him come up
to breathe every once in a while and at
some point my heel was supposed to come
off like it was going to dangle off of
my foot and go to the bottom and I was
going to tie him up and make him go to
the bottom of the pool and pick up the
heel with his mouth I mean it was that
level of detail down to the uh down to
the uh minute uh and and it was all
wrestling oriented in terms of like he
wanted me to be overpowering me powering
him this whole time that's his fantasy
yeah exactly um but he didn't live in a
place where I uh I think I ever traveled
still to this day I don't think I've
ever traveled uh because it was
definitely very rural and a lot of times
like I'll be like okay you can sponsor
me to go somewhere like you can pay for
my my flight you can pay for my my hotel
then you have to book at least a couple
of hour session um and a lot of times
like that's that becomes like 700 to
,000 which is just a lot out of the the
the um budget for these people uh for a
session that actually
happened um I feel like my wrestling
guys like I'm I'm a dominatrix as well I
feel like they are a lot have a lot more
specific desires um the wrestling guys I
feel like aren't as don't have as a
colle IC interests I did recently
wrestle somebody on my mats outside at
midnight in his yard outside yes and I
was like are your neighbors going to see
and he was like no they're like
80 his house was too he didn't have
enough he didn't have a 10 by10 space
that we could put the mats out so we put
the mats out on his grass in his yard
everyone is so much more interesting if
you really knew the the honest truth of
what their lives were about right
absolutely absolutely I feel like I wish
that we were more comfortable as a
society talking about that like I know
that in my neighborhood they all think
that I'm like the weirdo um but I'm like
I'm sure they all have stuff going on
too right
like hopefully I mean I don't know I've
met a lot of people who definitely
self-describe as
boring those are the scariest ones right
right and do you make a living just from
this or do you have other work that you
do I do not make a living from this uh
I've definitely met people who have have
uh but usually for you to make a living
you have to be able to dedicate not only
your time to traveling quite a bit but
to filming a lot really where the money
is right now like while sessions you can
make 350 I make 350 a lot of women at
this point make 500 600 an hour um the
uh like while you can make money from
sessions like you kind of advertise and
you make a lot of money selling your
clips and clips for sale and so you can
sell you can only fans probably or only
fans yeah only fans is a little harder
um I found just because um there's
either the subscription model or the uh
or like the pay-per-view and you can't
actually download the clips and a lot of
times that I've I've seen uh these
wrestling guys really want to be able to
download the clip and like rewatch it
and so a lot of them are really
interested in female versus female
wrestling um they like like watching
female versus female wrestling so
there's a whole subset of these guys
that like that's all they want so they
don't actually book sessions because
they want to watch two female they want
to watch two girls yes exactly do you do
that sometimes as well I do female yeah
I'm so actually after this I'm going to
uh I'm going to go shoot with um a local
a local model who um does some wrestling
stuff and we're going to do we're going
to do some like a couple of custom films
that will involve wrestling um but if
you can maintain your clips for sale or
your only fans or like whatever it is
that you're doing and even if you focus
on wrestling like you can make a huge
passive income and there's a couple of
like organizations that that's all they
do like up in Sacramento there's modest
moms wrestling like all like that's what
she does full-time is she films like
visiting wrestlers she doesn't do
sessions at all and all of hers are like
very PG like you could put them on
YouTube and they'd probably be fine um
and uh she she films like visiting
wrestlers and she does like very staged
Pro wrestle type stuff in the ring
that's in her uh garage and like she
makes a lot of money doing that and
there's another group in New York called
Doom maidens that they do a very similar
thing now they do they'll do some like
custom fetishy stuff too um or they'll
do like face sitting videos where you're
just pinning somebody by sitting on them
um but uh but like that's their whole
gig they don't even necessarily do like
not all of the girls that are Ono
maidens necessarily do wrestling for
sessions what have you learned about men
from doing this kind of work
uh uh
most of the time that they are super
awkward and really uncomfortable and it
is your job to you as when you're doing
this to make them feel comfortable and
to make them um sometimes they just want
to talk sometimes they really are there
for the conversation just like booking
an escort you know sometimes you talk a
lot during that um but they have like
this very specific Kink and it's a place
that they're able to do it um in in the
US when I've when I've wrestled in
Europe I would say that the men are very
pushy in a different way yeah different
cultures very different cultures very
different cultures yeah I don't I've
I've not people have always asked me
like whether I've had um like negative
experiences or like like people that
have tried to cause a problem or tried
to do something that we didn't agree to
not in the US like I can usually smell
it a mile away so I won't even session
with the ones that are likely to be a
problem have you done sex work outside
of this uh I've done mention diatri yeah
so I've done prodom work uh or
dominatrix work um and so I do that a
lot um some of my sessions have involved
uh sex over the years um but you can't
just email me and be like hey will you
come have sex with me and I'll pay you
like that's not that's not really what I
offer what I do um I have zero judgment
for the people that do I've lived with
um escorts before uh I just I don't
think that I'm good enough with um the
girlfriend experience to really make
that to really make that work for me uh
I think I think I'm
too in a lot of ways domineering for
that and this is certainly not something
that's for everyone this is this is only
a specific type of guy
right I don't know you know I feel like
wrestling's kind of a growing interest
like I've noticed locally that they've
started offering like wrestling days at
our dungeon um um and uh or like learn
to wrestle days um I feel like I've seen
more and more people get involved in
like Brazilian jiu-jitsu over the years
like there's a a fully woman-owned um
studio in in
Chicago um and so I feel like I've seen
a lot more interest in wrestling pop up
over the years I think people are
starting to see it at dungeon parties
like people will see the mats go down
and it looks like a lot of fun and it is
a lot of fun you know I really enjoy it
um and so I think anyone could wrestle
and have a good time with it I don't
know if it's for everyone in the sense
that like I don't think everyone needs
to pay a like fetish wrestler to have a
session with them um I think but I think
anyone can like roll around on the floor
for a little while yeah I could imagine
if you watched one of these
matches it it could be something that
really just becomes wow a guy might
think that that's something he wants to
do yeah I mean it looks like fun usually
the people that are wrestling are
laughing and having a good time that's
what I mean yeah um you know some of
these guys have very like like I have an
intake form like when you want to fill
it out and like when you want to book
with me and like I have like all these
options specifically for wrestling
sessions and like a pretty good portion
of them want Trash Talk uh that's a very
yeah that's a very common request so
you're giving them some attitude while
you're doing yes exactly yeah they want
me to tell them them they want me to
tell them that they and they'll give me
trash talk back too they'll be like oh
you're it's a joke right oh you're just
a woman you could never beat me or
something like that um what kind of what
kind of stuff are you saying to them uh
that how pathetic is it that they
thought that they had any chance with me
at all like they should know better by
now so you enjoy your work I do I do I
wouldn't do it if I didn't because I
have a day job I kind of sidestepped
that earlier unintentionally um yeah so
I have a day job I'm in marketing
um I have uh my MBA and my doctorate so
I'm uh I'm pretty involved in the
business world as my day job uh I just
so I do this as like my side hustle
essentially um and I got go through
periods of time where I don't really do
it a lot I've been renovating my house
this summer and so I didn't do it as
much and now I've had like an influx of
sessions this past couple of weeks espe
since about to have surgery and I'm not
going to be able to session for a little
while um but uh
but yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't do it if
I didn't enjoy it because because I
don't have to it's not my full-time job
and I have the luxury of being in that
situation whereas a lot of people don't
but I also kind of I've been doing it
for 11 years now um I've known that I
would it would be really difficult to
make this a full-time gig for me because
most of the people that are interested
in wrestling want a bodybuilder or a
standard sized woman like it's very
Niche for them to not only want to
wrestle but also to wrestle a plus-size
person and right now there's really only
two of us in the session world that are
known um and like we get paired against
each other all the time for customs and
or we did she hasn't Wrestled a lot
she's had a lot of um illness this year
but uh we get paired against each other
a lot like there's there's a whole like
basically fetish wrestling events um
like called the one was called women on
fire and it was in Vegas and then they
did it in Chicago one year too um and
it's the woman who runs the session
girls website which is how you find um a
wrestler and um she basically puts all
of the um all of these different
wrestlers together to wrestle on stage
as a part of the event and then in the
after party you can pay one of these
session wrestlers to wrestle you for
like 20 minutes and it's like $100 to do
that versus um versus like a full
session if you just kind of want get
taste of it and see if it's for you and
have you uh found there's you must have
websites or things like that where do
you where do you advertise what you do
where where can where can people find
you if they want to book a session uh
most of the time people find me on
session girls.com um it used to be wb270
but like I said that's gone down um I
have a Twitter as well that um some
people have found me through but I would
say that the majority of the Twitter
folks want a domination session whereas
the session girls folks like for sure
want wrestling sessions
uh I have a trist like a BDSM trist uh I
don't know if I've ever gotten a
wrestling session from that uh and I
don't really advertise outside of that
because there's just not a lot of places
to advertise like as a wrestler I can
advertis as a dominatrix who offers
wrestling are there are there guys who
discovered that that this was their
thing uh or do they know this was their
thing before they ever there are people
who have booked with me and it's their
first session ever cuz I'm very first
first time friendly a lot of wrestlers
or dominatrixes will not see someone who
has no references um I I don't know if
it's that I'm like really cocky or
really stupid but I don't actually like
I don't worry about that at all um so as
long as they give me the deposit like I
have information about them and like I
always have like safe calls set up um
but so I see a lot of first- timers a
lot of first- timers so I end up being
their reference if they go on to see
somebody else and uh and a lot of times
like they will be like okay I want to
try um wrestling and I want to try face
sitting and I want to try spanking and I
want to and like they'll go through the
list of things like because they don't
know what they want they don't know what
they like um and there have definitely
been a couple that have been like yes
wrestling for me for sure um and then
there have been others that have been
like nah like it was it was cool cuz you
liked it but it was it's not for me I'd
rather do the spanking or I'd rather do
the face sitting uh that's more that's
more my interest
uh there have been people who have ended
the session early because they've been
like yes I thought that I was going to
like that and I really it just didn't do
it for
me that's what makes the world go around
exactly all right Betty Brick House
thank you so much for sharing your story
thanks for having me super interesting
thank you so
much
that